Okay, so that would be a big reaction.
My name is Tony Vincent,
I'm a stunt coordinator
in the film industry.
It was an accident!
Listen to me!
Lets go.
After about 100 movies or so,
I started doing fight choreography.
I have a deep martial arts background.
Everybody's either known as
a fight guy, a wheel guy,
or a gymnast, a fall guy.
Fighting has always been my specialty.
I'm competent at the other skills,
but I've always been
known more as a fight guy,
and sought out for my fight skills.
When it comes to taking a
man with your bare hands,
it's rather risky isn't it?
James Cagney did a movie,
"Blood on the Sun."
And Judo was featured there.
Every era saw different things.
You know, the '70s was
obviously the Bruce Lee era,
and more of the Kung Fu flicks.
So then you know, I think "Bourne" kind of
changed some things, and
that was heavily based on
the Filipino art, Kali and Escrima,
and the stick and knife fighting.
So that kind of, I think, started
that different style of
fighting, was more realistic.
And I think it's here to stay.
"Raid: Redemption" series was
also done fantastically well.
"John Wick" was brilliant,
it was very heavy Judo-based.
They brought an art that was not really
shown that much in films.
Now go home and get your shine box.
One thing that I learned from my dad,
since he was an actor, is
what motivates the character?
Why is he fighting?
What is his ultimate goal?
Otherwise, it's just punches
and kicks and throws and locks.
So that's the first step.
The second step is,
what's the shooting style?
Do they like to hold shots wide?
Do they like to do a lot of
insert shots, flash cuts?
Because that'll help me know
whether I really need
to have a flow of moves,
or if it's gonna be cut
together in snippets.
Then we shoot.
We're gonna do a little
demonstration here,
and go over some of the techniques
to make fight scenes work.
We have here Ian and we have Aj.
The first thing we're gonna do
is put Ian to sleep, okay?
No, just kidding, okay.
(laughs)
What we really have to talk
about is selling to camera.
The camera, when stacked,
we're stacking right now,
it compresses the space in between.
So really, whether I'm here
or whether I'm here
or if I actually hit him,
it all looks the same.
Just to explain what I'm saying,
if I went like this now, guess what?
Well, that doesn't work,
we see a mile in between.
There's a couple of things
that I call "choreo-killers."
What we call bridging.
You guys are my friends.
I don't want to hit you in the face.
What a lot of people do is they go -
I call it bridging. Why?
We make it look like
it's the Verrazano, okay?
Because in our mind, subconsciously,
I don't want to hit you.
What makes a fight scene work
is not the person throwing the punch,
it's the person receiving the punch.
I always say, you want to
pretend that there is a pole
going through the top of your head
and running through your body.
So the first thing that
happens is your head goes.
Once your head goes, your shoulder goes,
then your hip, then your knee.
Now I really want you to
really throw it really hard.
Obviously, don't hit me, 'cause
I have meetings after this.
(laughs)
So go ahead.
Beautiful, okay good.
- Alright.
Now do it again.
Okay, so that would be a big reaction.
You are going to punch
him in the face, okay?
And then punch him in the stomach.
Then what I want you to do is
throw a right punch at his ear.
Someone's getting workers' comp today.
(laughter)
- Right, right, right.
Now again, this is a famous actor.
- You don't wanna hit him,
but you don't want to look
like you're throwing a little punch.
We're gonna do a half-speed rehearsal.
- Okay.
- Okay?
So half speed to feel it out
and know what you're gonna do,
and then we'll go full-speed, okay?
Alright, so I walk up,
like, "You got a problem?"
What's your problem?
- Hold on, hold on a second.
Did I say "action?"
Oh, you did not say "action."
So you're just running
the set on your own?
It's my first time on set!
- Okay, okay!
(laughter)
Ready, and action.
Alright, you got a problem?
You got a problem, man, huh?
Nice and slow, nice and slow.
Yeah, wham, good!
Good!
Good, good.
It's the full-speed.
Alright.
Cameras are rolling.
- Whoo!
- Okay, here we go.
Ready, and action.
'Sup, man, you got a problem?
You got a problem, man,
what's your problem, man?
Nice, very nice!
Very nice, good job, guys.
Good good good.
What's your availability next week?
I have a project for you.
- I'm free!
You're free?
Yeah, okay.
(laughs)
Thank you guys.
Thank you.